look at where america's at right now
what is america's biggest deal right now
and this has got nothing to do with what
you're doing but a part of it does
is
america is convinced
that rich people are bad people they're
fully convinced they're rich people are
bad people they're convinced when you
say we gotta tax the billionaires
do you know how many billionaires we
have in america seven hundred and seven
hundred and twenty billionaires in
america do you know what their total net
worth is four point seven trillion
dollars if you tax them a hundred
percent that wouldn't even be anything
close to how much money they printed the
last two years six trillion dollars and
you want to tax the billionaires but
because they say so many times from the
pulpit people believe the problem in
america's billionaires so what if people
from the pulpit said the problem is you
and i got to do something with our lives
if you can walk talk speak you speak a
language you understand people you feel
you have a healthy sense you your health
you have the ability to learn and
improve
you can change your life for the better